puede parecer una especie de sala de
juegos pero esto es un centro de
entrenamiento serio estos alumnos
pertenecen a las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas y están recibiendo formación
durante dos semanas para aprender a
pilotar drones con auriculares de
realidad virtual las municiones se
cargan más tarde
puedes ahorrar tu misil antitanque
porque el dron puede llegar tan lejos
como el javelin el dron cuesta unos 600
dólares un misil yabelincuesta entre
80.000 y 120 mil dólares
podéis venir aquí la tecnología avanza y
tenemos que avanzar con ella
los drones se ensamblan aquí en Ucrania
el reto es ponerlos en el aire más
rápido que Rusia que se está poniendo al
día según el responsable de este
programa
están intentando copiar lo que hacemos
nosotros primero fue con comerciales y
ahora con los drones inmersivos
kamikaces va a ser peor si alguien en su
gobierno se da cuenta de que se pueden
utilizar esta tecnología va a gastar
mucho dinero
Ucrania absorbe todo lo que puede de los
países vecinos todas las piezas y todo
lo que se produce en China lo encargamos
nosotros o los rusos
es el encargado de construir estos
drones kamikaces tarda aproximadamente
una hora en construir uno actualmente
trabaja en una solución para eludir las
contramedidas de las fuerzas rusas
utilizan estaciones muy potentes en
tierra para interferir nuestros drones
Así que lo único que podemos hacer por
ahora es que los chicos obtengan la
confirmación de kental o cual lugar no
existen tales contramedidas y solo
entonces vuelan una vez ensamblados los
drones Se entregan a las unidades un
capitán de las fuerzas especiales debe
recibirlos hoy Dice que
Necesita 100 de estos drones kamikaces a
la semana para su posición